it's 7 A.M here in Iraq's southern city
of smawa
time for Rashid and his friends to scout
the vast desert looking for something
rare and delicious
truffles
the March is sought after delicacy is a
fungal plant
that usually grows underground during
the rainy season
it usually grows five to Fifteen
centimeters beneath the surface we trace
it by indicators such as Telltale Grace
and cracks on the soil it's fun for us
because besides making money out of it
we also end up spending good time with
our families and have a picnic
atmosphere
every year between February and March
truffle hunters from smawa camp out in
the desert
to dig out as much of it as they can
pneumatic shepherds are no exception
Hussein Ali and his family set up their
tent around grassy fields for months
besides taking care of their sheep and
camels they also make a living by
selling the desert truffles
we have inherited the love of tracking
and collecting truffle from our
ancestors through years we spend most of
our life with our sheep and camels in
the desert but we wait for the Truffle
season every year to collect it sell it
and eat it it's a blessing from God
this is the Truffle Hub in the desert
here it is piled sorted packed and sent
to the city
but since they depend on Heavy Rain to
grow
some seasons will see little to no
truffles
the search process can be risky there
are wild animals here including wolves
and unexploded Ordnance beneath the
surface can sometimes be mistaken for
truffle
in the city's grocery market
Traders take pride in their produce
Iraq produces two main types of truffle
a light one and darker one
each piece of these can weigh between 30
and 200 grams and one kilogram can cost
up to 50 dollars depending on size taste
and quality they're costly here not only
because of a lack of supply
but also because of their flavor and
aroma
some restaurants in smawa serve it as a
meat substitute
desert truffles are high in plant
protein
similar to tofu and are a favorite with
vegans and vegetarians but they need to
be washed properly desert truffles have
new Roots so if they're not collected on
time
there'll be food for insects but for
those who rely on these rare Delicacies
they provide a much needed income even
if it means having to spend long days in
the Iraqi desert
Southern Iraq